the Xbox one has one fewer exclusive  coming this year I'm Tony and this game  spot news update is definitely a bummer  if you were looking forward to platinum  games scale bounds I'm sorry to say it's  been canceled plenty of Twitter rumors  were out there but now it's official the  decision was made by microsoft studios  after a long deliberation skill bound  was an action RPG featuring Platinum  Games trademarked combat and a bunch of  big awesome dragons hopefully some  concepts behind the game will go on to  be used in future titles losing  scalebound is disappointing but it's not  the only big Xbox one game plan for this  year crackdown 3 Halo Wars to see of  thieves and state of decay to are all  slated for 2017 keep an eye on gamespot  for the latest on all of those and for  all the biggest game news both good and  bad you're already in the right place